[موسيقى]
هذا المكان يقال له الحني قديما
والاشارات القديمه التاريخيه تشير الى انه
الفارعه او الموصل قديما قبل اكثر من 1200
عام هذه المنطقه الحني التي الان نجد لها
اثار ضخمه ولكنها كثيرا منها مندفنه الان
هذا احد المجسات المهمه لهذه المنطقه
لتقدم ايضا لنا صوره ما كان سابقا في هذه
في هذه في هذه الحي
نعم هذا الان نموذج قديم المدينه حجر
اليمامه يقدم الانسان له التصور قبل 1500
سنه النظام العمراني الموجود في حجر
اليمامه هذا نظام مماثل له وانا اذكر
الحقيقه قبل عشرين سنه اكتشف احد الباحثين
الزملاء الاستاذ محمد الحمود لو الحقيقه
الفضل بعد الله عز وجل في اكتشاف ايضا هذه
المنطقه ان يتمنى ايضا ان تزاد الحقيقه
البحوث واجراء الاكتشافات عليها لكنها
الان هذا التصور القديم المباني المعماريه
الطرز المعماريه الموجوده في حجر اليمامه
العاصمه التاريخيه لمدينه الرياض هذا احد
النماذج التي ننتبه لها الحقيقه وتقدم
ايضا لنا الفكره عن البناء العمراني في
مدينه حجر اليمامه
[موسيقى]
كم عمر هذا المبنى يقدر الان تقريبا من
اكثر من 1200 عام يعني البقايا التي وجدت
في هذه المنطقه تدل على انها اخرها احد
القطع العملات القديمه في سنه 127 من
الهجره فاذا بالتالي نجد الى ان هذه
المدينه اكثر من 1300 سنه على وجود تلك
العمله
التي في تلك الفتره نعم وهي بلده تابعه
لحجر اليمامه قديما ولا خارج حجر هذه احد
البلدات الملحقه بحجر اليمامه قديما حجر
اليمامه هي العاصمه المركزيه لمنطقه
اليمامه وتوجد عن هذا المكان تقريبا من
الجهه الشماليه قرابه 87 كيلومترات لكن
هذه البلدات القديمه المتصله بوادي حنيفه
وهذه هي احداها
[موسيقى]